in other Kardashian news oh and other X
blast from the past Kim Kardashian is
calling out Ray J's bluff of course they
used to date and you remember their
infamous sex tape she is calling him a
quote pathological liar that's what Kim
Kardashian is saying about new claims
that Ray J is allegedly making it all
began when the outlet the son published
a report claiming that Ray J the singer
had spilled on the couple's former sex
life to partygoers at an event in London
on Thursday nights now allegedly among
his alleged claims were that Kim had a
Louis Vuitton trunk full of questionable
toys that she would stop while they were
while they were messing around together
that she would stop doing that to
instead do her makeup that she'd spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
lingerie that she would be calling her
mom a lot as they were close to being
intimate very interesting so these are
all alleged claims from the Sun about
things that Ray J allegedly said but Kim
responded to a fan on Twitter and here's
what Kim is saying he's a she's saying
that what these claims could show is
that he's a pathological liar you
actually believed this story question
mark it's too funny to me she says all
right well Kim Kardashian laying down
the law no matter what was actually said
or not over a blast from the past with
her ex Ray J
[Music]
[Applause]